the pockmarked ground in Ukraine has
become the Hallmark sign of Russia's
scorched Earth campaign and once again
it's the most defenseless that have
fallen victim there was a very loud
sound I couldn't understand what was
going on this woman says she works in a
nursery in Ukraine's Donetsk region a
Russian missile one of three landed
nearby this part of the country Remains
the front line of this war and while
Ukraine has shown Fierce resilience
Russia is regrouping the Kremlin must
lose Ukrainian president Volare
merzelenski spent this past week
pleading for allies to do more at a
meeting of NATO defense leaders on
Friday the block reinforced its
commitment even though not everyone is
on the same page this is not a moment to
slow down
it's a time to dig deeper the U.S has
approved another two billion dollars in
Aid it doesn't include sophisticated M1
Abrams tanks that is partly why Germany
is holding back on supplying its leopard
two tanks we are not really hesitating
we are just very carefully in balance
and all the pros and cons and while
Berlin is stopping Any Nation using its
tanks including Canada from providing
them to Ukraine it hasn't ruled it out
in the future the war started by Russia
does not allow delays every unit helps
to save our people from Terror
Germany is among the Nations providing
the most support and NATO is warning to
not get caught up in one conversation
over tanks the complex of an army is
much more important than any one of its
individual Parts Russia sees all of this
assistance as a continued provocation
but not a hurdle to a war it believes
can be won despite setbacks and unending
drive by Ukraine's military
Reggie chickenie Global News Washington